10,098 Egra players need to see this.
Egra H. Yeah, there are some words I
never seen before on a Magic card. I'll
build it. What's the deck going to do?
Oh, I'll find out as I play. Then you
realize your commander doesn't actually
do that much. It's just a giant
doing the eating. I mean, it's 10 out of
10 flavor. How the turntables, but
that's about it. Your opponent's
creatures looking real vulnerable here,
except it's them who will decide to
consume or not. And thanks to you, they
now have sacklets in a pinch. Sure, have
your two counters. I'll drain everyone
for 15. Sure, have your two counters.
I'll go get my omniscience. And don't
forget the three lives, says the Eg
player. Yeah, they almost think you're a
group hug player. If it isn't for the
1616 commander you have, they got to be
real scared. Wait, why are they not
scared? Oh, yeah, because Egar doesn't
know how to trample. Attack. Oh, is that
a senior citizen with a death wish? Oh,
I guess we're done for the day. How
stupid do you feel? And this is where
the card today comes in. Tower of the
Magistrate. Read and process.
I mean, half of you play Rogu's Passage.
Hey, let's play spot the difference.
Yeah, and the difference here is the
tower costing three less and doing so
much more. Maybe your opponents tries to
kill Yigra with a ravenous chupacabra.
Haha. Protection from Chupacabra. And
not only can their creatures not touch,
they can't even touch each other. My
mother gives me protection. You have
protection from your mother. There's
actually a lot more, but I know your CPU
here is overheating, so I must stop. And
let's just say this one card probably
has more play than the rest of your deck
combined. Thanks for watching.